vous avez eu l'immense honneur de faire
la connaissance des sols à l'eau vous
êtes en danger tout de suite
ouverture plantes numéro 6 soyez la
bienvenue à l'agent styles je dirige un
groupe secret de femmes exceptionnelles
vous êtes genre des excuses
nous travaillons selon les propres mots
dans la clandestinité en simple
vous ne connaissez peut-être pas notre
existence mais nous veillons sans
relâche
c'est vous avez eu l'immense honneur de
faire la connaissance des changes alors
tu viens enfin la formation moi mais
c'est oui tu vois comme ça il va falloir
que tu poses cet avion à tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
ok
[Applaudissements]
assis bien en évidence franchement vous
avez absolument pas le droit de toucher
quoi que ce soit sauf si vous avez le
droit de le faire
[Musique]
le plus sympa dans tout ça c'est pas
d'arrêter l'activité à l'autre avec lui
si vous l'ifi
siroter un verre aux journées c'est ce
que je préfère au monde
[Musique]
conduisez landes récifs d'emprunter
c'est la règle officielle
les anges on se met au travail
[Musique]